- Well, I haven't eaten
anything yet today,
so this is my breakfast.
- I picked my nose as a
kid, hell yeah, who didn't?
- Quite often, actually,
this (bleep) ain't new.
- If it was itchy, I liked scratching it,
whether it was my head,
my butt, my ding dong.
- Oh, 100%, I still pick my nose.
- If I'm driving and I'm really bored.
- I definitely roll it up
into a little ball, flick it.
- I either flick it out the window,
or flick it to the passenger's seat.
- I'm not the only one
who does that, okay.
- But I certainly don't eat it.
- Yeah, I, yep, used to eat 'em.
- I think anybody who says they haven't
eaten their boogers, is a liar.
Kids do stuff.
They put fingers places,
and they taste it.
- They're kind of salty, I remember.
- Salt and dirt, I don't
know if ya had dirt before.
- It'll be like, revisiting an old friend.
- So, I'm gonna find a booger now.
- I got a lot of nose hair,
so this'll probably be easy.
My nose hairs are like, longer
than some babies' (bleep).
- I feel like I shouldn't
let you watch me.
- There's no like attractive
way to pick your nose,
I don't think, oh.
- Oh oh, I found one.
- I got something, oh, that's
nice, right in the crease.
- Oh.
- Could I try for another?
- Oh, that was a good one.
- This is definitely a big enough booger.
You can get some flavor in this one.
- Oh my gosh, there's a hair in it.
- I'm gonna mush them together
to make one giant one.
- This is like the Ruby
Tuesday of boogers.
- Actually, there's
two hairs in it, fudge.
- What sucks is that I have to suck it
like it's Cheeto dust.
- Now that I'm on camera,
I don't feel like doing it.
- Okay, nope, just one, two.
- Feel like such an asshole.
- It tastes like my boogers.
- That was, mmm.
- Yeah, no, that's
exactly how I remember it.
- A little aftertaste goin'.
- Dissolves very easily and it has excited
my mucus, my sinuses.
- It tastes like the clear Gummy Bears.
- It tasted just kind of
like a unsweetened mochi.
- Uh-hm, oh, I went in
for seconds (laughs).
- It wasn't as bad as
I thought it would be.
- I was afraid.
I was really, kinda nervous.
- It's just like salty goo.
- That was fine, I wonder if there's
any protein or anything in that.
- I think it's good that kids eat boogers.
Yeah, it's a life
experience you definitely
need to have as a kid.
- If you're still eatin'
boogers as an adult,
make sure no one's looking.
- It's like what goes in,
must come out, and then,
go back in again.
- Picking your nose, in general,
maybe there shouldn't be such
a big stigma on it, ya know?
Cuz it's just a thing, we all do it.
- It tastes better than ear wax,
which, ear wax is really gross.